STACY SULLIVAN:
Well, you can see
how popular you are
within the Googlers.
So I wanted to welcome
Ana Ivanovic to Google,
to the Googleplex.
We're so excited that
you're here visiting today,
that you're here for
Bank of the West.
So hi everybody,
I'm Stacy Sullivan,
I'm one of the old
time Googlers here.
I'm also the-- quote unquote,
the executive champion
of the tennis team, the
Google tennis team which
has won the league
the last couple years.
So, yay to us.
We've got a lot of strong
players here at Google.
Ana is a former
world number one.
Now in your 11th year
on the pro circuit.
Ranked 11th in the
world currently,
has won an impressive 14 WTA
single titles in your career,
including one Grand Slam title
as the 2008 French Open singles
champion.
She became a UNICEF National
Ambassador for Serbia in 2007,
named one of the 30
Legends of Women's Tennis
Past, Present and Future by
Time Magazine in June 2011.
And as far as I know, does not
sleep in a hyperbaric chamber,
like Novak Djokovic.
As I was coming
over here, my group
was asking if you sleep in that
oxygen chamber like Djokovic.
I said, no, just because they're
from the same country does not
mean they all do that.
And no, they are not dating.
They all want to know,
like, do they-- no.
Separate person,
she's incredible,
and we're so happy
to have you here.
And in true Google
fashion, we'd like
to have a Googler, an avid
tennis player and coach
himself, Jonas, who's hit
10 years now at Google,
conduct an informal
interview today.
Just so we get to
know Ana a bit more.
So we're really limited
on time, so we're
going to keep questions going
for maybe 10 or 15 minutes,
and then open it
up to the audience.
JONAS: All right,
thanks for coming.
We had a little bit
of a chat outside,
I tried to prep you for
the room a little bit.
So, I'm a tennis
player, but I think
we have a lot of tennis players
at Google in general, people
really excited about the sport.
And so just so that we
know who we're talking to,
who's a test tennis player
in the audience, real quick?
ANA IVANOVIC: Oh my God!
JONAS: So we have 200
tennis players right here.
Cool, who's a fan of Ana's?
ANA IVANOVIC: Now you
put them on the spot!
JONAS: I know, how
could they say no?
So I think we're all
really excited to have you,
and so you've had a
really, really good year,
I think, last year.
And was wondering
if we could maybe
talk a little bit about that.
So what happened this year,
compared to the last three
years that you played,
that gave you two titles?
I think you beat Serena
at the Aussie Open,
and did a few other things.
So what changed?
ANA IVANOVIC: Yeah.
First of all it's my
pleasure to be here.
I've been to Stanford
a couple of times,
and I think it's exciting
to see a little bit
different side of the
city, and to see something
other than the tennis court.
But yeah, I think this
season has been great for me.
I actually have
three titles, and I'm
making quarterfinal the
first year at an Open,
beating Serena.
And I think, not only in
sports, but in life in general,
you go through ups and
downs, and you learn.
And I started this very
young, and as Stacy mentioned,
I've been on tour for 11 years.
It makes me feel really old,
even though I'm not that old.
But you have the
different experiences,
and this year has been
good, and I'm really
enjoying competing, and
going through the challenges.
JONAS: So did you
change anything
in terms of how you
practice, or did
you tweak any of your strokes?
Or do fitness stuff,
or did anything
make a difference in your game?
ANA IVANOVIC:
Everything a little bit,
but it's mostly
all in the mindset.
You know, when your mind is
set, when you have certain goals
and you work towards something,
and you have a big picture,
makes it so much easier to
know you have a purpose.
And everyday you try
to improve, and you
try to learn, and
try to get better.
JONAS: OK.
So we have a new coach,
was just in the news,
we had a chat earlier
too, so welcome.
So when you pick a new coach,
what are you looking for?
What's important to
you in your game?
ANA IVANOVIC: Can you please--
JONAS: I think we're OK.
ANA IVANOVIC: Well I think
it's very, very important
to understand each other
and to communicate well.
Because tennis is
such a specific sport,
because it's an
individual sport,
you spend so much
time with the person.
You really need to get
along, but also the coach
needs to understand the
way your game develops,
and the way your game should be.
Because every player
is different, and yeah,
I think it's very important
to find someone who's
going to motivate you,
inspire you and support you.
I think the support
is very important,
because people see us competing.
And on court, we are on our own.
But there is so much more
to it, behind the court
and behind the scene.
And all the hard
work, it's actually
done off the match court.
JONAS: Yeah, I watched you
guys practice a little bit
yesterday, and I see a
lot of laughter on court.
You missed the box, but we're
not going to talk about that.
Today, you made it.
OK.
So they were trying to toss
tennis balls into a box,
and it was mixed results.
So how important is that,
to also have a lot of fun?
You know, there's a lot of-- you
have pressure, there is media,
there is these things.
So what does humor and
fun have to do with it?
ANA IVANOVIC: I think it's
very important, you know?
Because like I said, we do
this for so long and we travel,
and it's not easy.
We are always on the road,
not with friends or family.
And it's very important to
have that laughter, and joke,
and understand each other.
Because there is time
to be serious, but there
is also time to be
relaxed and fun.
And we try to play
jokes on each other.
Yeah.
And try to make it
more fun for everyone.
JONAS: OK.
And then Stacy just
mentioned, so you're
playing tomorrow, Bank
of the West Tournament,
just across the street.
So how do your days before the
tournament usually look like?
So how do you
organize your days?
How much do still practice?
Do you still tweak little
things here and there?
Or is it--
ANA IVANOVIC: It really depends
where in the season we are,
and this is the first
tournament after the break.
So I had a fair bit
of practice lately.
This morning I
practiced only once.
And yeah, normally I do
that, I do some recovery,
and then I basically
relax and read and then
have an easy dinner later on.
And just try to rest and
be fresh for tomorrow.
But in the lead up, I had
a little bit more of work
and a lot of gym.
JONAS: Right.
And then do you still-- like
when the tournament is coming
up, do you still tweak
little things here and there?
Like with your work on, I don't
know, like footwork stuff,
or maybe change a little
bit of the strokes?
Or is it really more about
finding rhythm, and just
getting used to the
conditions and everything?
ANA IVANOVIC: Of course,
finding rhythm is a priority,
but we will always work on a
few little specific things,
you know that-- maybe one
day you don't feel so good.
Whether it's a
volley, or a return,
or a serve or something that
we'll tweak a little bit,
and also adjust depending
on the opponent you play.
JONAS: OK, so some
people in the audience
know, I lost my topspin
backhand a little bit.
ANA IVANOVIC: That
happened to me too.
JONAS: OK, so we'll
talk about that.
Look for it together.
So what do you do in that case?
So if you feel you lost
confidence a little bit
in a stroke, how
do you get it back?
ANA IVANOVIC: It's hard, because
actually it's all in the mind.
But the mind can be
such a tricky thing.
And I think it's very important
to just go back to the basics.
And trying to move your feet,
because once you're nervous,
or you think you lost the shot,
the first thing that stops
is the feet.
And then you're not in a
position to hit better.
So then get back to
that first moment.
It's very important to try
and get that flow happening.
And also try to let go,
even if you miss a few,
and try to get it
out and then sort
of start from the beginning.
JONAS: OK.
So we have in the
audience today, obviously
a lot of tennis players.
There's a former
touring pro, and we
have something
some younger folks.
I know you started around
when you were five,
and you played a lot.
What advice do you have
for our younger players who
would want to come up,
and maybe give it a shot
to become a professional
tennis player?
What's the-- is there
a most important thing
that you would tell them?
ANA IVANOVIC: I think
it's a few things that
have to come together.
But I think the
most important is,
if they believe they have a
shot, to really commit to it.
Because there is no
doing it half way.
They really have to
embrace the competition.
And enjoy it as well.
And try to be
passionate about it.
And like I said before, you
have to wake up with a purpose,
and think this is what I want to
do, and what I want to achieve.
And only then, you're honest
to yourself and say OK,
I gave you the best shot.
And yeah, I think tennis
is such a fun game,
and every point is different.
And I think that's something
that I enjoy doing.
I feel if they're-- want to
pursue it, and they enjoy it,
I think they should go for it.
JONAS: When you were growing
up, I assume you played a lot,
you drove a lot.
It wasn't that your
parents said, Ana,
you need to play more, we want
you to be a professional tennis
player.
Where did that
motivation come from?
ANA IVANOVIC: It was a
very specific situation,
because I wanted to play
tennis, and I watched it on TV,
and I was very stubborn
since I was very young,
so I was like, I want a play.
So for fifth birthday,
it was my present,
and that's how I started.
No one in my family ever
played tennis before,
and they still don't.
Which is a good thing, I guess.
My brother always jokes
that I played with everyone,
but never with him.
Which is kind of true,
and sad at the same.
But yeah, but I had full
support from my family.
And I must say, in tennis we
have lots of crazy parents,
and I'm very proud that my
parents are not one of those.
JONAS: We used to joke
about that at home, too.
So they're sometimes more
ambitious and intense
than the kids themselves.
ANA IVANOVIC: And then I
think that's very important,
that kids start to realize that
it's their dream if they want
to pursue it, and
not that they're
doing it for their parents.
Because sooner or later,
that's going to wear out.
And then they're going to be
stuck somewhere in between.
So I was very fortunate.
JONAS: So I was in
the same situation,
but I didn't make it on tour,
but Google is not bad, either.
ANA IVANOVIC: Beautiful.
JONAS: Yeah, so we were
just talking-- actually
you were just asking
me outside what
we're doing here and everything.
So in general, we're a lot
about data, technology, gadgets.
There's a lot of sensors
coming out on the market.
And one thing that
I'm interested in
is, how has technology
changed the game for you?
You've been on tour
for 10, 11 years--
do you feel an impact
of technology at all?
So we all know Hawkeye,
rackets, Wii Play, stats,
so anything that
really changed for you?
ANA IVANOVIC:
Definitely, I think
that technology changed
the game so much.
Basically from the first
time I played on tour
until this moment, I feel.
With better strings,
better rackets,
I feel there are
much more players
who can produce a sort
of power, if they are not
a powerful player.
And then helped to sort of
even the game a little bit.
So the talent is not as
vital as it was before.
Because now you can compensate,
if you're not a big hitter,
you can get looser strings.
Or if you hit flat,
you can get strings
that give you more spin.
So in that sense, it
changed tennis a lot,
and it did get
faster and stronger.
They tried to slow
the courts down,
so they still make it
more fun for, I guess,
audience, and also for
us a little bit harder.
But yeah, it did change a lot.
And obviously Hawkeye
is a big part, too.
JONAS: Do you feel the games
getting more and more similar,
between the different
surfaces, is that---?
ANA IVANOVIC: Well, the
movement is a lot different,
when you change
surfaces, that's sort
of the first thing
you want to work on.
But the game itself, still on
clay, you can use more spin,
and grass courts are
a little bit faster,
and flatter and lower.
So you can see the difference
from surface to surface,
but it definitely got
a lot more powerful.
JONAS: So I have to ask you
one weird question, as a tennis
player.
So we have-- a lot of people
in the audience are always
trying new rackets and
changing weight balance and all
that stuff.
How much has your racket string
set up changed over the years?
Have you found
your perfect setup?
ANA IVANOVIC: Minimal.
JONAS: So you
still pretty much--
ANA IVANOVIC: Exactly.
Changing rackets
and strings, it's
like a little bit
changing technique.
Because obviously,
technology is improving
and you have little
tweaks here and there.
And I've been very fortunate
in playing everything
on [INAUDIBLE] now,
five years six years?
So they do improve, but
it's always similar balance
to the one I'm used to.
There is not that much of a
difference, which is important.
Because you find
something that is good,
and to get used to something
completely different,
it takes a long time.
JONAS: OK.
Cool, so I'm sure we have a
room full of questions here.
AUDIENCE: I don't
have a question,
but I think it's a nice thing
to welcome you [SERBIAN] Google.
ANA IVANOVIC: [SPEAKING SERBIAN]
Very nice.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
again for coming.
I was just wondering, During the
first few games of any match,
how do you try to dictate the
pace and style of the match
to sort of to suit
your game of play?
What are some
things that you do?
ANA IVANOVIC: Well
this is something
that I've talking to my
coach a lot about this week.
And just starting the
matches, because it really
depends what kind
of form I feel.
And if I feel the
ball really good,
i will start really
aggressive, sometimes
I will start a
little bit tentative.
But we spoke about
this, and that it's
important in these
first few games
to sort of impose
your game, and to try
to still swing true
and get that rhythm.
Because then the opponent
will feel more pressure,
and then sort of set
the tone for the match.
So it's very important to let
go in the first two games, sense
and try to go for it with
exaggerated movement footwork.
AUDIENCE: Hi Ana.
When you prepare
for your matches,
do you look at a lot of
data about your opponent?
ANA IVANOVIC: That's the
job the coach normally does.
Yeah, so if you
have any research,
you can give it to him.
No, but I think it's very
important, because even
though we played against
each other a few times
and we know a lot
of players, still
it depends what
kind of form they
are, depends on the
surface as well.
So coach does the research
and then we speak about tactic
before the match.
AUDIENCE: When you
were number one,
did you notice a big change
in how you were perceived
by the public, by the media,
by your sponsors, by everyone?
And was that a big
change from being
number one versus number
two, let's say, or lower?
ANA IVANOVIC: Yeah, it was.
And when I became number one,
I was only 20 at the time.
And it was-- because I
was very shy as a kid,
so it kind of was
a big shock for me.
And I didn't really know how
to handle that spotlight.
Because all of a sudden
there was so much attention,
and it brought a
lot of pressures,
a lot of expectations.
And up to that point, I
didn't have any of that.
So to get used to that,
it took some time.
And yeah, like I said,
I was only 20 years old.
So also very young and immature.
So since then I
think I changed a lot
and I got some more
experience in that area, too.
AUDIENCE: Does it
ever happen when
you're playing a game
that at some point
you just feel like it's
just not working out,
and then you give up?
Or is it the coach who is
constantly telling you?
ANA IVANOVIC: I blame the coach.
No.
Yeah, definitely
during the match
you sort of experience
many different emotions
and feelings.
And I never give up,
but sometimes you
get really frustrated, and
then you want it even more.
And the more you want it,
the further it gets from you.
So it's like a catch-22.
So it's just very important
to try and stay in the moment.
AUDIENCE: Sort of a
two-folded question,
but one, as you ascend
the rankings again,
have you changed
anything in your style?
You mentioned your
racket and the strings
have basically stayed the same.
And two, there's
been a lot of talk
about the gluten-free diet.
And I think you tried
it at one point in time.
What were the things
that you learned
from that experience
that worked,
and some things that
may not have worked?
But I'm curious if you changed
how you eat to prepare.
I know you've been on
tour for a long time.
And two, if you're changing your
strategy to a certain extent
to deal with today's
power tennis.
ANA IVANOVIC: Yeah, that's
a very good question.
Actually, to perform
on such a high level,
you actually have
to tweak everything.
You can't let anything
hang in the air.
You have to sort of
prepare yourself,
and do the fitness,
do the tennis.
And also nutrition, it's
such a big part of it.
Because like I said, tennis
has developed so much,
it's so much
stronger and faster.
So recovery is very important.
And nutrition is
a big part of it.
So I do take, for example,
like, is a tonic something
that will help me stay
hydrated during my matches?
Use gels for energy and so on.
I do try still to
eat gluten free,
and if I have opportunities
so I eat a lot of rice,
and protein is very important.
I do like meat, and eat
a lot of meat and fish
and all kinds of protein.
But yeah, I try to stay
off the dairy so much.
I try to carb load
the day before I play.
ANA IVANOVIC: And then, like
I said, before my matches,
I also try to eat
light, but still some
carbs that will give me
energy for the match.
AUDIENCE: Do you find
that over the years,
do you come to a period where
you just feel burned out?
Or do you feel like
every time you play,
you're just like, happy
to play and glad to play?
ANA IVANOVIC: Well,
there is definitely
times where I wish
I was on holiday,
and I don't want to be on court.
But I think it's normal.
I'm sure not every
day you look forward
to the day in the office.
Everyone goes
through these phases,
and we do compete a lot,
and we travel a lot.
So it does-- it's very
stressful on the body and mind.
And all the pressures that come
along, and other activities we
have to do.
So it's very important
to find this balance
between working hard, competing,
and then also resting.
And that's why we have
to make smart schedules,
and give body and mind a rest.
Even when sometimes-- in
the beginning of the year,
I was four months on the road.
And it's very hard, you don't
see your family, friends
and it's a constant
competition and pressure.
So whenever I have
a day or two off,
I really try to do something
different to engage in.
Sightseeing, just to get
your mind off tennis.
And that's a little
trick that we
try to do so we can
stay motivated on court.
AUDIENCE: What's one
lesson, or one thing you've
learned throughout
your 11 years on tour,
that's really helped you?
Throughout the 11 years-- you
stayed playing for 11 years?
ANA IVANOVIC: Well, when I
was about 11 or 12 years old,
my coach at the time
in Serbia told me,
it has to be hard
on practice courts,
so it's easier
during the matches.
And it stayed with
me, and it's so true.
Because you really have to work
so much harder on the court,
so then when you play matches
it's just a piece of cake.
JONAS: All right, nice.
Thanks, guys.
So we have a little
present for Ana,
and [INAUDIBLE] now is going
to come and get that out.
Also want to say super,
super big thanks to Tracy,
[INAUDIBLE], and Stacy
today for all their work.
ANA IVANOVIC: Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
That's very nice.
JONAS: And then you
get some more practice
at tossing the ball, practice.
So anywhere you like.
So, we have some
signed balls from Ana.
Nice.
All right.
ANA IVANOVIC: OK,
I'll go further.
JONAS: And the last one.
Oh no!
STACY SULLIVAN: And we wish
you good luck tomorrow,
in the match.
JONAS: All right, well
thanks for coming.
ANA IVANOVIC: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.